should we should we talk let's talk
about uh impeachment first
just a little bit to go over the uh some
of these issues
more importantly we were talking a
moment ago matt was mentioning that
there are many people who are involved
in the capital
you know the storming of the capitol who
had no idea what was going on
and now they can't get lawyers so i i do
want to go over that a little bit but
we'll start with
you know where we're at with trump
because the big news i suppose
if you care about impeachment and it's i
i i find it really really hard to care
about it
is that his lawyers are doing miserably
like really really bad
and trump is apparently really angry we
have the story of the new york times
that says
meandering performance by defense
lawyers and rages trump
the former president was particularly
angry at bruce l castor
jr one of his lawyers for acknowledging
the effectiveness
of the house democrats presentation well
apparently the democrats have put up
some like
they're arguing over his tweets they put
up some edited video to make their case
i honestly just think it's a big waste
of time because we know it's gonna
happen in the end right
yeah it's it's not gonna there's not
gonna be a conviction and
so the problem i think that the
president's attorneys have
is they don't understand what's going on
is that they are making this very narrow
constitutional argument they're almost
doing this in a very bad way as if
there really is um something to be
decided as if they were in a courtroom
as if it was truly a case and it's not
any of those things
this is an old-fashioned soviet-style
show trial
but unlike in the soviet system you
actually both sides get to do a show
so and i've used this term before it's
asymmetric warfare with
the left the democrats are rolling in
here with it's just the loudest part
they know they're not going to get a
conviction
it's basically just about trashing
republicans trashing trump
trashing his supporters and they're just
it's full on
propaganda and they're not they're
throwing everything in there like
high impact video granted it's edited
and it's phony et cetera
but then the republicans walk in and
they're like making like a legal
argument like it's some
you know republicans are dumb well
you know these attorneys i i'm not sure
how committed they are to the party
because uh
they're democrats so i'm just saying and
uh one of them sued the president twice
just a year ago
so what what what yes why why did he
hire these people
you know i i'm not privy to that process
but i'll tell you i
i've heard from many people including
very prominent republican attorneys
more than one by the way who have just
been dumping on the performance and the
thing is look
if it's a show trial you you fight fire
with fire you roll in there
with all the instances of the left in uh
uh provoking riots
like serious riots resulting in people
getting murdered
cops being murdered cities being burnt
to the ground democrat politicians
calling for
people to stand up and fight and and you
go whole hog and you can you know
you can go anywhere you want you can
talk about chinese
influence compromising president biden
and some of the steps he's already taken
with his administration so far
you can do whatever you want it's like
it's a blank canvas so just get in there
and paint the best picture you can but
these guys i
the thing is i i almost feel like they
they're phoning it in because they know
what the outcome is and they're like and
they're thinking you know
a year from now this will be completely
forgotten because it's you know you know
maybe that's the right thing and i
actually respect that it's a waste of
time
we don't need to waste any time on it
they should walk in and go uh donald
trump has free speech
and uh you know he didn't do it uh we
rest our case that would be brilliant if
they did that but instead they're doing
like a real legal as if it was a real
impeachment trying to make a real case
and doing a bad job of it
i remember looking through twitter i
forgot who said this but someone
jokingly said it was definitely the deep
state that made
donald trump hire and ept lawyers which
is which is a very interesting point the
independent also has a very uh
curious article that reads trump's inept
lawyers draws comparison to joe pesci's
character
in my cousin vinnie vinnie uh if you
remember that movie that was a pretty
funny movie back in the day i loved it
myself but again a lot of people are
criticizing these people but
more importantly a lot of mainstream
media people are treating this like it's
the super bowl like
like everyone cares and in reality no
one really cares
what else are they going to energy but
what else what else is there exactly and
you would think they would take this
opportunity to move forward with their
agenda their causes but they're stuck in
this again
trump derangement syndrome they're stuck
talking about trump and no no no and
they're beating a dead horse no luke
they're the dealers
they're the dealers of the drug they're
the ones dishing out the trump
derangement tablets to all the
unsuspecting
towns children they've been dipping into
their own stash a little bit yeah
yeah they're high on it they they have
been but i think now they know they're
dealing
they're dealing trump arrangements well
here's the question we got to ask last
time there was
this a phony impeachment um that was
completely consuming all of capitol hill
and the entire media
right at the time this little flute like
thing
was starting to spread out of china and
slowly
reaching other parts of the world just
no one's really paying attention to it
president trump made comment about
fighting it in his state of the union
speech that pelosi tore in half and
ignored and
then called him a racist for trying to
limit travel to china
that's that was what was happening when
the last impeachment trial was consuming
everything
so i wonder what's what are we missing
now because
this is what they're completely focusing
on i mean joe biden's weird executive
orders
like the one that allows for chinese
propaganda
52 of them or 52 so far one two two yeah
that's a reference to that
that time story oh yeah i mean but
they're bragging about that they're not
trying to hide it
no i i maybe maybe it's the electrical
grid rule suspension joe biden's
allowing chinese-made goods to be using
our electrical grid suspending a rule
from trump for like seemingly no reason
and i've actually heard criticism from
some people who are relatively
you know democrat saying i understand
trump's rules may have been bad but
shouldn't you review them and not shut
them down first like
don't suspend the rule just review it
and then if it comes
you come to the decision to get rid of
it then you do isn't it weird to like
just immediately snap your finger and
say china you can build stuff for our
electrical grid
we're going to review if it makes sense
or more and more mil u.s military
convoys
going through syria yeah what's the
status of that i've heard about that i
heard it was debunked with
syrian propaganda no there have been
several of them at this point now and
nobody's really pushing it or asking
questions yes there's been many kind of
international organizations that have
been detailing large convoys 50
plus vehicles going into syria into of
course the northeast region where the
territories contested between
syrians kurds russians and now the
united states that is permanently
watching all the oil fields there as if
it's theirs so that's that's happening
and slowly but surely the reports that
are coming in is that
more and more troops are on their way
there and it's always american troops
coming through iraq is that what it is
well it's not just iraq there's also
jordan
the united states has bases all around
not just
you know syria but of course iran there
so there's there's a lot of troop
mobilization and movements not just by
the united states but also russia in
that region as well that is also
doubling down and sending more troops
into that region
i wonder what they're going to do with
oil when the economy is shut down and
nobody's using it
yeah that's another big factor here
economically especially with you know
america
becoming energy independent now under
these new restrictions by biden
it looks like the united states is going
to have more of a kind of appetite for
oil so that this is why some people are
saying we're going to be going back into
the middle east i think it's far
beyond that i think it's far beyond
natural resources
there's bigger things at play here
especially the geopolitical
hegemonic power play that's being made
between russia china and the united
states on the world stage
yeah the shipping lane through the suez
canal is not to be understated that's
that's
of course the central blood flow of the
united states shipping yeah if you look
if you look at major conflicts
throughout world history they have taken
place
on shipping routes so shipping routes
are essential this is why china also
expanded its territory into the south
chinese
sea because it's along a major trading
route that of course
usually sparks the largest conflicts
when we look back at history
it usually it concludes first the
stopping of trade that's interesting
because the us
is running uh drills right now under
biden in the south china sea yeah with
japan and australia doing war games
uh of course kind of saber rattling
against china who has been also
doing a lot of consecutive war games
especially in the month of january in
january out of 31 days
for 30 days china ran drills and
ran over the airspace of taiwan
uh specifically drilling for its
invasion so so sorry guys but
i'm so this sounds really important but
don't you we've got an impeachment
no you're right you're right yeah that's
a good point
international war is meaningless no no
forget about that stuff so he's getting
impeached
wow you mean he already got impeached
wait
that's right yeah now they're going to
try and convict him i can't even joke
about this
and who is this guy you say it's they're
trying to impeach the president of the
united states
donald trump say his name with me guys
donald
trump that's all about donald trump he's
not the president right he's playing
golf
and they're like we got to convict this
citizen i think that before
trump there wasn't that much news i feel
like maybe i'm desensitized to it i
can't tell i'm in this warp world
you got you got pulled into a vortex
we've all been in yeah they were they
were making
so much news because his tweets and now
it's just kind of back to normal
there's not that much news well this is
hillary's pr i'm sorry pelosi's
priorities but i will tell you that if
they weren't doing this right now
their their fundraising would just crash
i mean even npr was talking about this
immense legal battle that's happening in
florida right now with the local county
trying to kick trump out of mar-a-lago
saying that he can't live there
permanently i'm like why are we
obsessing about this why is npr talking
about this and they went on for a full
30-minute segment
i love listening to npr because i love i
actually really like their their science
and technology
uh sections when they talk about those
issues but politically it's very
interesting to see their perspective
because i love to see how other people
think
and they are non-stop obsessing about
this impeachment they're thinking it's
the super bowl it's a major sporting
event they were covering it live
play-by-play blows and when you look
online there's not even a forever no one
really cares everyone's over it everyone
wants to see but this is this is the big
moment that we're in because everyone
wants to see what the democrats can do
for them
we voted for the democrats they got
elected
they're in there what are you going to
do for me what are you going to do to
make my life better people are waiting
there and they're like
we've got trump here we're going to
we're going to beat this dead horse
even more like they're saying it's very
simple yeah i know
america that you voted for the
democratic party and we here
we democrats are going to do everything
in our power to get you exactly what you
need in these trying times
by impeaching a guy who's not president
anymore hey
put on the clown makeup drop the circus
tent put on
music and then yeah a little car drive
around and people are swinging around in
the trapeze and like oh donald trump's
getting impeached
don't look over at the decimated small
businesses
don't look over at the mass evictions
that are looming
because we've got a big old pile of
bread and circuses right here for you on
the tv
i mean the american people are hurting
just like i brought up in my
introduction failing wages collapsing
economy loss of civil liberties huge
health care costs
i don't see any of the democrats dealing
with any of these issues have you ever
at all of course not but there's going
to be a lot of disenfranchised
new voters because i mean how many votes
did joe biden get he got more votes than
any other president
in american history so there's going to
be a lot of people who are like i
participated i was a part of the system
i got evil trump out now things are
going to be better
and now they're going to be slapped in
the face with reality no here's
corporate globalist america
screwing you family-friendly show i got
i got other things i want to say here
we're going to say it save it for the
post show uh but but they're ramming you
with their corporatism and you have no
other thing to do
than submit to them getting their own
way and it's ridiculous and it's
sickening
we could talk about mandalorian or wanda
i still want to talk about foreign
policy
yeah i love foreign policy i want to
talk about the vestigiality of uh
the political establishment at this
point it seems like there are no value
you know in a gland and your body
becomes vestigial it's no longer used or
needed
uh it seems like they're just like you
said meandering at some point well no
they they are siphoning away our money
yeah
used for their lifestyles partly because
they're incapable of handling the money
because they've given the power
of the money over to a private company
and they're just letting the federal
reserve run with it so they can't fix
monetary policy they can't even audit
the federal reserve but but let's not
underplay
when they're like i must have 10 million
dollars for pakistani gender programs
and speed boats
in sri lanka giving themselves raises of
course they're good at that the raises
thing i don't really care that much
about i do
i can't stand it that's not that should
not be their authority that drives me
insane want to get a raise
i love them self arrays with my money
well so the problem is there's no real
way to solve the salary problem of
congress
like andrew yangton said give him a
million bucks so they're not
incentivized to work for lobbyists
but that wouldn't change anything
they'll still the lobbyists would just
offer more money the companies would
offer more money
and some have said make it so they can
only make as much as the median american
job and then they'll be taking the the
lobbying
it's like there's no real way to solve
that problem i'll tell you the bigger
problem is when they're like
we have to help america by sending 500
billion dollars overseas during a
pandemic when people's
jobs are destroyed we'll give your
dollars to
someone else in a different country with
different rules and less lockdown or
what we desperately need a new industry
i don't want to derail this
particular conversation but i i think a
lot about graphene you know and
if we can make america uh like the
graphene industrial power of the 21st
century i think that that will
that's just one small component i mean
it'd be like if we were the steel
industry of the 1900s now we can be the
graphene industry i think we have to do
it you know
with these politicians that don't
understand it it's not going to happen
no
new people well i think impeachment is
dumb
sounds like you should run for office my
friend yeah that's right the graphene
party i'm behind you let's do it
and the fed slogan let's do this you'll
get smeared thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you